- [Gary] I think influencer
marketing is gonna have an
incredible golden era
of a decade.
I think we're in the beginning
of it and I'm very fond of it.
I think it's underpriced.
I think the top is overpriced.
So the people that moved
quickest and have big audiences
I think are overpriced because
people think they're more
valuable than they are.
You got to look at engagement.
The amount of people that have
a million fans on Instagram but
they don't
really have community,
things like that,
but I'm a very,
I mean word of
mouth always worked.
- [Man] Right, right.
- [Gary] So, I'm very bullish.
My recommendation is don't run
around saying that
you're an influencer.
Think about how to
bring value to your audience,
create influence
and then monetize it.
Again, we are living
through the greatest era of,
again, you just put on your
profile and you think you're it.
That's like me putting
on my profile right now
basketball player.
(audience laughter)
Cool but I'm not getting
paid by the Knicks, right?
And so, like just
saying you're an in,
the amount accounts that
like hit me up on DM like,
"Yo, I'm an influencer."
I click it and I'm like you
have 800 people following you.
Yeah but, I'm
like, no, no, no, no.
You're not an influencer
by definition of
anybody's influence.
So if you have that in your
profile put a
word in front of it;
aspiring influencer.
(audience laughter)
But it's,
I'm very bullish on it.
- [Man] Great.
- I think it's
underpriced right now.
I also see because it's human
beings a scenario where in two
or three years it's
gonna be grossly overpriced.
You just have to
follow the market.
Right now, it's underpriced.
- [Man] Right.
(light music)